- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our Homeroom livestream,
Sal here from Khan Academy,
really excited about the
conversation we're about to have
with David Banks, who is really
one of the leading educators
in the country, president of
the Eagle Academy Foundation.
But before we get into that,
I will make my standard announcements,
a reminder to everyone
that Khan Academy is
a not-for-profit organization,
we can only exist through
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate
and donations of all
size make a difference.
I also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have helped us
over the last few months, really.
Some of these well
before that, many years,
long time supporters.
But when they saw that we were
already running at a deficit
pre-COVID, and that deficit only increased
'cause our costs increase
'cause obviously,
our server costs have gone
up, two to three X of normal,
we're trying to accelerate a whole series
of programs and content.
So special thanks to Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
fastly, Novartis, and many others,
in helping us close this gap,
as we are trying to step
up in any way we can
to get the country and actually the world
through distance learning and
actually get to a place where
a personalized education
and learning not being bound
by time or space becomes a
norm and not an exception.
So with that, I'm really
excited to introduce David.
Hi David, good to see you.
President and CEO of
Eagle Academy Foundation.
- Good to see you as
well, Sal, appreciate it.
- So David, maybe a good place to start is
tell us what is the Eagle Academy?
And why have you put so
much energy into this?
- So the Eagle Academy
is a network of all boys
public schools in New York City,
where we work with young men of color
from grade six to grade 12.
We've got a school in every
borough in New York City,
as well as one in Newark, New Jersey.
So as we sit here today,
we got 3,000 young men
across our schools, and have
graduated about 2,000 young men
over the years and sent them onto colleges
and universities across the country.
We started in collaboration
with the 100 Black Men
in New York, really as a response
to the national crisis that we have seen,
so many of our young men have faced,
where they've not
graduated from high school
and not presenting themselves
for opportunities in industry.
Getting caught up in getting incarcerated,
caught up in the criminal justice system.
All the things that we hear
about on a regular basis,
but there's really been relatively
little response to that crisis.
And so, Eagle Academy was
created really in many ways
as a response to give young men a place
where they can hope and dream,
and reach their full potential.
- And there's at least two
really interesting things
that might be surprising for some folks,
that you just mentioned.
This isn't your
traditional charter school,
these are actual public
schools in the New York City
public school system, I guess
in Newark in one case as well.
And then the other surprising thing is
you don't hear a lot about
single sex schools anymore.
This is a school for young
men, at risk young men.
First of all, how does
the first thing work?
How does a branded system of schools
within the public school system work,
and why did you make that decision?
And then why the decision
to focus only on young men?
- Well many years ago, when
Mike Bloomberg was the Mayor
of New York City, he cast a wide net
in terms of trying to
get other not-for-profits
and organizations to get more involved
in the public education system.
And in doing so, we became
part of the 21st Century
Education Reform Effort that
was happening in New York,
sponsored by the Gates Foundation.
Where they said, listen,
this is a huge system
and we need others to get involved.
And so that's when our
organization, 100 Black Men,
decided to get involved.
Over the years, it had
become politically incorrect
to have single gender schools.
But we leaned into that
space really to say,
what is it that causes young
men to believe in themselves
and to focus on their own potential?
And I was the principal of the school.
We created it in the Bronx with
a group of ninth grade boys,
and quickly realized that if
we were going to do this well,
we needed to start earlier
than the ninth grade.
And our model soon after,
became a grade six through 12 model.
But we were intentional in
saying that we wanted it
to be traditional public schools,
because philosophically,
we really felt as though
you can't charter your way
out of this education morass,
charters oughta be a big part
of the response in education,
but over 90% of high
school kids in America
still want a regular traditional schools
like most of us went to.
And if you can't move
the needle in that space,
you're just playing around on the margins.
And so we wanted to be able
to lean into that space
and that's what we've done.
- And what does it look like?
What's different about an
Eagle Academy public school,
other than the single gender focus?
What are y'all doing that
you think is different?
And what have you learned
that has been particularly effective?
- Several things.
It's about the culture that you establish
that says to young men that
we deeply believe in you.
And that may seem like
something really simple,
but it is not.
You have to remember that 80%
of teachers across America
are white and female, and
don't necessarily have
a background or training
in how to work with boys.
First of all, there's some
significant differences
between the energy that boys
can bring to the classroom
and that girls can bring
to the classroom, broadly.
But when you start talking
about boys of color,
there are some unique
challenges that those young men
bring to the classroom everyday.
And there's a unique
energy that they bring.
And very often, the boys find themselves
getting disciplined in school,
being called out for things
that are really not bad behavior,
it's just having teachers
having a level of sensitivity
and understanding who the boys are,
what their backgrounds are,
and recognizing that there's
a certain way, as adults,
that we have to show up if we wanna get
the most out of these young men.
So we engage them in all kinds
of professional development
and training for our teachers
around what does it mean to
meet the boys where they are?
We've got expanded day programming.
That really is about what are the things
that boys are really interested in?
We've got game rooms.
You think about it.
The boys love to play video
games, but yet in schools,
we don't often utilize the kinds of things
that boys are interested in.
We use a one size fits
all kind of approach.
Boys love to compete,
but they don't like to compete one-on-one.
They wanna compete my
group against your group.
So how do you frame a
spirit of competition
into how you do your day-to-day
interactions in school?
But one of the most
important things that we do,
it's just about the culture
of saying to young men,
we see you, we recognize
all of the challenges
that you face on a daily basis.
We have a daily town hall
meeting for half an hour
before the young man stepped
foot into a classroom.
We pour libation and they get
a chance just to reflect on
what's happening in their lives,
and the trauma that so
many of them are feeling
each and every day.
That's not the kind of
thing that you can measure
in a standardized test,
but it's the kind of thing
that says to the young men,
we see you and we're here for you.
And it makes all the
difference in the world.
- I can imagine that's very powerful.
And I wanna encourage everyone
watching to put questions
on Facebook and YouTube
about really anything regarding education.
And it could be a single gender education,
it could be this question
around public schools,
charter schools,
it could be how we're
gonna do distance learning,
and we'll talk a little
bit more about that.
But David, as you've gone on this journey,
I guess how many, first of all,
how many years has it been?
And what has been kind of
your, maybe some of your things
you've been struggling the most with
that you're still trying to figure out?
And then what have been
some of the big wins
that you're like, wow
that's a powerful data point
that shows that we're on the right track?
- Well, there are a few things,
Sal, I would tell you that.
First of all, I've been in
education for over 30 years
myself, having been a teacher,
an assistant principal,
founding principal, not
only of the Eagle Academy,
but have a wonderful coed
school in the Bronx, as well.
So this is a space that
I've dedicated my life to.
There are a number of
things that we have learned
in the space for boys, but we've also seen
very broadly really
for boys and for girls.
Internationally, there've
been some studies
that have been done around boys.
And the biggest thing that emerges is that
boys disconnect from school
because school is boring.
The connection to what
they're doing in class
to what their real interests are,
very often are not aligned.
And most teachers will tell
you that, they recognize that.
But they struggle with how to figure out
how to make that connection.
So intuitively they know
that boys checkout easily.
But you gotta figure out
how do you make your lessons
more fast paced, more engaging,
in order for boys to really stay focused.
And they've gotta be relevant.
You've gotta be talking about issues
that really do make a difference.
And that's where I think
we begin to see the overlap
between boys and girls.
I'm a firm believer,
after having spent three
decades in this space,
that we are doing education the wrong way
if we really want everybody to win.
And what I mean by that, Sal, is that
we've got to reimagine,
we've got to recreate
how we are doing the education experience.
And so what I mean by
that is that you've got,
I think we do a really
good job of schooling,
but not necessarily such
a great job of educating.
And there's a difference, right?
There's the routine of
going to school everyday.
But when you think about the
fact that in New York City,
if somebody sends me their child at pre-K
and I have them all the
way through 12th grade,
that means I've had them for 14 years.
And in New York City, if you
had a child for 14 years,
we taxpayers have spent over $300,000
on each one of those children.
So you kind of say, well what's
our return on investment?
You got kids who come
out after 12th grade,
they can't tell you the difference between
a Congressman and a Councilman.
They don't know, if they
wanted to start a business,
where to even begin.
There're just too many things
that we are not aware of.
And one of the things
I'm deeply troubled by
is the fact that you look
at a presidential election,
only 56% of age eligible Americans
even vote in a presidential election.
That's a little more than
half of our population.
Why is that?
Why are people so apathetic?
I think that is because we
don't prepare young people
through that K-12 experience
to be engaged citizens.
We hang that slogan up in
every school in America,
but that's not actually what we practice.
We practice kids getting ready
to take standardized exams,
that don't necessarily
have any real relevance
to what their lives
really should be about.
And that's what I have seen
in that space with boys,
I've seen it in that
space with boys and girls.
If we don't figure out ways
to make their education
much more relevant to
their day-to-day lives,
we will just be doing the routine
of going to school everyday,
but not necessarily preparing young people
what they need to be
successful in their future.
- And so, as you engage, arguably a lot
of what you're saying
applies to both genders,
but as you engage in this way,
what are you seeing of your graduates?
Are they being more successful in college?
Or are they just more
confident in their lives?
What data points have
you have you seen so far?
- What we have seen is
something that sometimes
is difficult to measure.
And so, how do you measure grit?
How do you measure determination?
That's something that people have really
been struggling with.
Everyday at Eagle Academy, our young men
recite the poem, "Invictus."
And "Invictus" is the poem of resilience.
It was the poem recited
by Nelson Mandela everyday
when he was locked up on
Robben Island for 27 years.
It was the favorite poem of John Lewis,
who just recently passed away.
It's a poem that really talks about
when you get knocked
down, how to get back up.
Well we talk about that
poem, and we recite that poem
across with all 3,000 of our
young men each and every day.
And that poem really
represents what we want
from our young men, to know
that life is going to hit you,
and you're gonna get knocked down.
But our young men who have
gone, who've graduated
and gone off to colleges and universities
across the country, have
been able to persevere.
We've been able to get our
numbers, graduation numbers
higher than the national average.
And we believe that's
because our young men
may not come out with
the highest test scores,
but they come out with
something inside of them,
which talks about how to stay focused,
that when the going gets tough,
you've got to continue
to fight and to press on.
And that your destiny is
wonderful and full of potential.
And that is what the
whole Eagle experience
has really represented for them.
And that's what we
continue to push forward.
Listen, we're still very
much a work in progress.
We're still learning everyday.
We're very much a learning organization.
But our young men have been
doing well, and doing us proud.
- Yeah, no, I could imagine.
And a lot of great questions
coming in from social media,
from Facebook (mumbles) is asking,
are there strategies
already in place to educate
the parents simultaneously,
to engage them,
to nurture their kids, and
the importance of their role
in their kid's life while
educating and nurturing the kids?
I believe that parents
and teachers equally
play an important role in
how we shape their thoughts,
actions, and upbringing.
Thoughts there?
- Huge part of the work
that we do at Eagle.
One of the reasons why
we've been as successful
as we have been, is because
we don't just talk about
parents being involved and
engaged, we practice that.
We let our parents know
we are partners in this.
So let me give you one example
of something that we do
that most schools across America don't do.
We gather our parents
for community gatherings,
with their teachers and
principals on Saturday mornings.
Now why is that important?
Because the traditional
Wednesday, Thursday night
after work meeting is something
that people have been doing
all across America.
We lament the fact that lots
of parents don't come out
and don't get involved.
Well, they've got other kids,
they've got two or three
jobs, it's really tough.
And that's because we
generally set our schedule
of how we want parents to be involved.
We set that in a space that
benefits school personnel.
It's good for us to show
up on a Wednesday night,
we're already in school,
we just stick around for
a couple of extra hours.
But we had an idea that if we met parents
on Saturday mornings, we could
get them much more involved.
And it has been absolutely amazing.
The response that we've
gotten from our parents
when they show up on Saturdays,
we've encouraged them to take the lead.
And so it's not just the school principal
who has to run those meetings,
but the parents themselves
are leading the work
and the efforts.
And how you engage the community,
it's a huge part of the DNA of what we do.
And a big part of reason
why we've been so successful
with our young men, because their parents
have been running this
race side by side with us.
- I love that idea.
A lot of the things
we've already mentioned,
feel like things that many
schools can replicate.
These aren't like completely
re-engineering everything.
Making sure that kids feel supported,
believe in themselves.
I love "Invictus."
So I love the fact that
y'all are reciting that,
or invoking that everyday.
Having Saturday meetings,
so it's much easier for parents to engage.
A lot of questions coming in.
From YouTube, Smart Bear asks,
David, I guess you already
talked a little bit about this,
why you started Eagle Academy,
but what are your inspirations?
Maybe I'll broaden the question.
Describe this path.
You've talked about spending
three decades in education.
Why did you pick,
what were you like in high
school and middle school?
What brought you down this path?
And at the end of your career,
what do you hope you can look
back on and say happened?
- I didn't go to school
initially to become an educator.
I started out as an engineering
major at Rutgers University.
And after a couple of years, I
switched to political science
with the intention of going to law school,
which I ultimately did.
I started teaching and having a family,
and then went to law school at night.
Left education, never thinking
that I was coming back,
and worked for the New York City
and New York State Department of Law.
But as fate would have it,
I was really supposed to be
working with young people.
And I came back and became
a school administrator,
and I've had a wonderful career,
and am absolutely living my purpose.
- So let me just ask one question on that.
So you were a practicing lawyer?
And then you somehow went into become,
I mean, what was that?
I famously, I was a tech
guy, hedge fund analyst,
started tutoring cousins, Khan Academy.
How did you make that transition from
being a practicing lawyer to
being a school administrator?
- Well, it was because I
really, as a person of faith,
I just, I felt my calling was,
while as a child, I thought
I always to be a lawyer,
but as I got older I
realized that my real calling
was working with young people.
And so I decided to go
back into education.
And I went back and I got my certification
to be a school administrator
in one semester
by going to three
colleges at the same time,
which people have found
to be somewhat inspiring.
But for me, it was just an example that
when you're very focused on what it is
that you're supposed to be doing in life,
they say the universe will
conspire for your success,
and doors will open if you're
prepared to put in the work.
And I was prepared to put in the work.
So for me on a personal level,
that's kind of how I
got to be where I'm at,
kind of being back in
this education space.
But I was inspired around
this work of Eagle Academy
because Columbia University
put out a report that said that
75% of the state's prison
population was coming from
seven neighborhoods in New York City.
So you think about that, Sal, right?
75%, if you look at the
entire state of New York,
75% of the inmates were coming,
not just from New York City,
but from seven very specific
zip codes in New York City,
this is where people of color are.
Central Harlem, the Lower
East Side, Southeast Queens,
Bedford-Stuyvesant, it's the communities
where black folk are.
And people knew it.
People were writing books about it,
they were analyzing data,
it was all kinds of
research and write papers.
But at the end of the day,
it seemed like the most you could hope for
was a good afterschool
program for maybe 20 kids.
And I said, no, we
gotta do more than that.
That's the reason why we leaned
into creating Eagle Academy.
Not that Eagle would be
the answer as a cure-all,
but we certainly wanted it to
be a learning space for us,
a lab, if you will, to figure out
how do we get these boys
to believe in themselves?
How do we get them to avoid
the lure of joining gangs
and being on street corners?
And even for boys that
don't get caught up in that,
who just never reached their potential.
How do we get mentors into
the lives of young men, right?
You recognize that almost
70% of Black boys in America
are growing up without a father at home.
The hip hop generation, in many ways,
is a fatherless generation.
So boys become of age and they
don't have men to help them
navigate the transition
from boyhood to manhood.
And then when they get it wrong,
we blame them, as a society.
And so we said, we wanted
to lean into that space,
to try to figure out some answers.
And that's the journey
that we have been on.
But what we have learned are lessons
that we think are good for
boys, as well as for girls.
So I'll give you an example,
how can a boy dream of
becoming an investment banker,
if he's never met one?
You've gotta open up opportunities
to activate the power of
possibility for young people.
If all you see is a very
limited number of things
in your own neighborhood or on your block,
it's hard to even dream
of doing great things.
So how do you bring an astronaut in?
So folks get a chance to meet them
and help them to demystify
what does it take
to become an astronaut, or a scientist,
or an investment banker, or
an architect, or a politician?
These things don't just happen,
you've gotta be exposed.
And that's one of the things we recognize
with so many young people,
particularly young people of color,
who are not getting exposed
to the possibilities.
And that's where I think we
have great opportunity now,
even in spite of this COVID pandemic.
What it has thrust us into
is a space where technology
can actually be the
space that closes the gap
on so many of those opportunities.
Where you can use technology,
where you can show young people,
what does it mean to work at
a Wall Street finance firm,
or a Midtown law firm.
You don't necessarily even have to always
take the trip there, but you
can be exposed inside the walls
and meet with those kinds
of career professionals,
just like we're doing right now.
And young people are ready.
And I think, thank goodness,
so many of our adults,
because we've been Zooming everyday
have gotten much more
comfortable in this space.
Think about this, as well, Sal.
The implications in our classrooms.
If you have a school that
doesn't have a good math teacher,
now the school, the kids are
not getting good math results.
Well, why should we be limited
by simply that math teacher
that's right in front of us everyday?
Why can't you take the best
math teacher that you can find,
they may be in Detroit, Michigan,
but through technology,
why can't that person
teach those kids in Harlem?
If you had the vision to do that,
we now have the tools to close this gap
in ways that we never had before.
And that's what I mean when I
say thinking out of the box,
being much more imaginative
around the possibilities
of what we can do through
the use of technology,
it can help to transform the
lives of so many young people.
- And that kind of makes
me think about obviously,
the circumstance we're in
with distance learning.
I am curious, obviously
everyone's been talking about
the pros and cons, mainly
cons of distance learning.
But you're also saying that
there are some silver linings
and things like this.
How are y'all navigating it?
And what do you hope is lasting,
coming out of this crisis?
- We've got something that
we call a virtual village,
where we have engaged
with our young people
on a regular basis, even
throughout this pandemic.
We're getting ready to roll out
something that we're
calling a masterclass,
where we're gonna bring in
experts from all kinds of areas,
but all of our young people
will have an opportunity
to be exposed to, that
they would not normally
get that exposure in their
day-to-day schooling experience.
So think about it.
So many young people are
interested in sports,
they're interested in music,
they're interested in the music industry.
But you get very little exposure to that,
throughout the normal
course of your school day.
But what we're doing through
this masterclass series is
bringing in people who are
well-versed in all those areas,
who can come in, and now just
share with these young people,
all of our young people.
If you're interested in getting
into the music industry,
here are the things that you need to know.
These are the skills
that you need to have.
That's why it's gonna be important for you
to continue to do your homework,
and stay very focused in your
English and your math classes,
because you're gonna need
these kinds of skills.
What if you want to become
an investment banker?
Well, first of all, what
does that even mean?
And so for young people to hear from folks
who can demystify that process,
that's the space that
we're touching on now.
But we're getting ready to
blow that out in a major way.
- No, that's incredible.
And that's completely gels with
what a lot of we've been saying.
You know, a lot of people associate school
as the place to learn content standards.
And it is that.
But it's also the place for socialization,
place to be inspired,
place to be supported.
And that's not often
explicitly stated in standards.
But especially during distance learning,
it's a lifeline for
kids to a broader world.
So that's really powerful
what you're doing.
A bunch of questions here.
So Smart Bear, you
answered this a little bit,
why only boys,
I guess Smart Bear's
question, like why not girls?
Is there kind of a corollary?
Are there sister schools
that are addressing that?
Or just maybe the need?
It sounds like you were
motivated by to some degree,
this incarceration issue in
a fairly concentrated way,
which is disproportionately boys.
Are there other elements?
Do you know folks who are,
is there a benefit for
a girl only schools?
Is there something there?
- Absolutely, in fact, when
we opened our doors in 2004
with the very first Eagle
Academy in the Bronx,
and I was the principal of the school
for several years earlier,
there had been schools
that had already been opened up for girls.
And so our sister schools in many ways,
the Young Women's Leadership Academies,
they opened up about four
or five years before we did.
And they had already opened
up at least three schools.
And in some ways we
balance the playing field.
So the question was being asked of them,
well hey, what about the boys?
And so Eagle Academy came as a response.
And so Hillary Clinton
and Claire McCaskill,
and other senators at the time,
put forth legislation
that essentially allowed
for the proliferation of
single gender schools.
But the caveat there was that
if you have a boys school,
there oughta be a girls school.
It doesn't have to be started
by the same organization,
but the school district itself
ought to be putting in place
a similarly situated academy for one,
as well as providing
for the other, as well.
And that's what we've been doing
across wherever you see an Eagle Academy,
you'll see a girls school.
They're not run by our organization,
but that also in place.
- Yeah, no time always goes by fast
when we're having an
interesting conversation.
One last question is,
longer term over the next few years,
how do you see yourself scaling?
How do you see, is the Eagle Academy a lab
that other people will replicate?
Is there a higher level policy changes
that you think we can make to replicate
some of the work you're doing?
What do you think is
the five, 10 year path
to getting more impact?
- Yeah, so where we
are as an organization,
we're not gonna be opening
up more schools per se,
certainly not more Eagle Academies
because we don't believe that
a brick and mortar approach
is the way to go,
but really looking at Eagle
in many ways as a lab.
So there are school
districts that wanna open up
an all boys school like
ours, not an Eagle Academy,
but something similar.
And we have set ourselves up
to help to support schools
and districts like that,
through what we call the Eagle Institute.
So the Institute is set up
to help to train school districts.
We helped Los Angeles open the first
all boys public school in their history,
called the Boys Academic
Leadership Academy.
It's built on the Eagle Academy model.
But I will tell you Sal,
that the bigger issue
is that is not single gender schools.
No matter what you do, there're gonna be
a limited number of single gender schools.
The bigger issue is, what have we learned
in working with the boys
in the single gender model,
that will help teachers in coed schools
who struggle everyday with the boys?
And that's where our work
over the next 10 years
is really gonna be focused on.
We've already started that
in a number of places,
where we're training the educators
in these school buildings
and in these districts.
And we're expanding on that
work now across the country,
to help to teach them the
most promising practices
around how do you get
the most out of the boys
who are in your classroom?
Because across America, it's the boys
and it's the boys of
color, who are the ones
who at the bottom of all
the indicators of success.
So if you can lift them through
the work and the teachings
and the things that we've learned,
you will by definition,
be lifting your entire school anyway.
And I will just leave you with,
that one of the most
important things is about
how do you engage these young
men in relevant education?
If the things you're doing are just about
doing the routine of school,
because we just supposed
to go and do our work,
that's not gonna get it done.
Kids have got to be engaged in things
that they can see outcomes
in their own lives
and in their own communities.
And it can't simply just be about
we're preparing kids to
take standardized exams.
And then if you do standardized exams,
well we say it's a great school.
Kids may not know much
about anything in life,
but we say it's a great school
because they did well on exams.
That won't get it done in working with
the kind of population
that we're talking about.
You've gotta talk about real world issues,
and how they can wrap their
hearts and their minds,
and then work around
that, and develop skills
around solving problems
in their own communities.
- No well, David, this
fascinating conversation,
obviously we've met in
many contexts before,
but I look forward to,
one, seeing how we can
help on this journey,
and learning from all
of the incredible work
that y'all you've done
and are likely to do
in the years ahead.
Thank you for joining us.
- Look forward to it,
thank you so much, Sal.
- Well everyone, thanks again
for joining our Homeroom livestream.
I look forward to seeing y'all.
I think we're gonna go pick up next week.
But as you can tell, I'm never,
I live my life hour to hour.
I need to look at the
schedules a little bit better.
But anyway, stay safe and keep learning.
And I'll look forward to seeing y'all
on the next livestream.
Thanks everyone.
(chimes)